hi everyone
hi bffs wow happy election day
vote vote vote vote vote
voting and america have always been so
important to me and i wanted to show you
actually these photos of me voting from
previous years
yes i directed a documentary to
understand and learn my civic duty
um and i love this country and i wish
everybody truth and safety today as
we've hit the official day
of election i am proud to be from this
country i am honored
to get to live in this country and i am
we
are in the words of tom petty an
american girl
[Music]
except for you gentlemen then you are
american gentlemen
but i am an american girl oh speaking of
american girls
get a load of this special one they sent
over to us for the show
wait for it yep it's the new drew
barrymore doll
thank you american girl and mattel fyi
it's a one-off but more importantly
guess what
courtney's got a friend
oh they can go to the salon
oh these are the things that just really
do it for me
you know what we're gonna go up down and
all around
[Music]